[Music]
all right it's time to dance and talk to
jill in today's money watch we're
talking about student loans in just a
few weeks on may 1st a pandemic error
freeze on federal loan payments is set
to expire more than 36 million people
have not had to pay their loans since
march 2020. that's about 195 billion
dollars in payments cbs news business
analyst jill schlesinger joins us right
now on what borrowers need to do how you
doing this morning i'm doing well all
right dollar dollar jill let's talk
about it so for two years the government
have has given students a little bit of
breathing room but where does it stand
now well remember this is just federal
student loans so that's 1.6 trillion of
the 1.75 trillion loans outstanding they
are federal so most people do have
federal loans right there's been a lot
of talk about maybe this is going to be
extended again i get a lot of folks who
come into my podcast who say well i'm
just not going to pay well i don't think
that's a great idea i think we should
prepare so that we don't have to panic
so really start focusing in on may 2nd
that's the day there is also a little
bit of talk about maybe there could be
actually the expulsion of student loans
under say ten thousand dollars again
it's talk there is nothing in stone that
chatter has been going on for quite some
time he sure has nothing has been
confirmed nope not yet 36 million people
are likely gonna have to start making
loan payments again how should they get
themselves mentally and financially
right and mentally of course go to
studentaid.gov you want to start
updating your information so for a lot
of people they were paying during this
zero percent interest window that's a
good idea it shortens the time frame but
you've got to make sure all of your data
is collected the right way you're
signing up for an auto debit you want to
check out your payment options while
it's this very strong labor market some
people maybe are not making as much
money maybe there's an income driven
repayment plan that's in your future
compare it look at it don't just do what
you had done so we know that may 1st is
national decision day where students
have to make a choice
get an emotional girl
something in my throat where they have
to decide make a decision about where
they're going to apply to schools yeah
do you have advice about what kind of
colleges you how do you base that
decision because money really matters
when you're filling out those
applications and deciding where don't
really want to matter it matters
exactly right you don't realize that
this can follow you in the future for
decades and times right so here's what i
want you to think about you get these
financial aid award letters there's a
real problem with these letters there's
no uniform way that each college must
write down here's how much is a loan
here's what a scholarship is here's what
a grant is here's what the interest rate
will be so you've really got to do some
homework with these letters i'd like to
offer two guidelines for parents and
kids about borrowing right okay if
you're the kid and you're the student
you want to target your total borrowing
for what you think your first year
salary will be okay
okay because we have so much information
it's great so according to most recent
data class of 2020 average first year
out of college 55 thousand dollars okay
okay now if you're a liberal arts major
maybe that's thirty thousand if you're a
software engineer maybe it's eighty
thousand you're a student try to borrow
limit your borrowing to what that first
year salary will be okay parents okay
increasingly are paying the more of the
bill for a family here's a way to think
about it what's my household income
that income is what i can borrow in
total for all of my children so let's
think about that two people they're
together you each make fifty thousand
dollars you've got a hundred thousand
dollars of household income you got
three kids you cannot borrow or cosign
for more than a hundred thousand dollars
why we don't wanna rob you of your
financial foundation the last thing any
parent wants to do is say oh you know
what i would like to retire can you help
me honey i'm glad you enjoyed your
college education well here's the right
most people in america don't have a
four-year college degree and a lot of
people are looking at these numbers and
thinking why am i paying 25 30 000 a
year that's going to get me a job paying
the same amount
or less
this is really important it is worth it
with an asterisk the average college
graduate makes about a million dollars
more over the course of a career that's
big money right and that's 15
more than the non-college graduate but
again you cannot borrow too much to get
there and also very clearly you must
finish school there's no partial credit
for getting three out of four years down
you've got to finish or else it will not
work jill schlesinger you have had the
last word today oh my